so this is about a recent work with Chi
su gyeong hands on your own from Christ
it's a title is constructive algorithm
four pathways of matrix so I'll first
give some background like the basic
notation and some history and what has
been done and then so the background
will be about a half the talk and about
10 minutes or so I'll give up very like
rough I'll try to convey some feel about
how the algorithm will work and if i
have time then i'll mention supplication
of the algorithm okay here is a quick
reminder of what maitre d's so actually
the algorithm itself doesn't rely on the
maitre d self so we don't even use the
word metroid in the most of the
technical section but yeah because it's
about maitre d just let's begin with
what began with matt what maitre d's so
a pair of two objects II and I is called
maitre d if they satisfy the following
so is called the ground set consists of
elements and is a family of software of
the elements in in the ground set so if
I satisfies the three the following
three properties then this pair is
called maitre d so what is the property
so first the empty set should be in this
family secondly if if Y is in this
family I then for any subset for any
subset X which for any subset of Y
should be again in the in this family
and for any two subsets from from this
family if the size of X is smaller than
the size of Y then you can pick some
element from y so that you can augment
eggs with this new element Y and this
again belongs to two thousand I so this
said is called independent set and
at you know the the obvious object the
satisfy these three conditions is the
set of column vectors in a matrix in a
matrix right so obviously the column
vectors or matrix forms are may trade
with the independence that defined as an
independent set of column vectors and
the maitre d which can be represented as
matrix the matrix which is represented
as a matrix even has a name which is
called a soulmate radius set is
representable in a field F if there is a
way to have vectors in a vector space
over this final field F and there is a
way to by actively match the elements of
this ground set and the vectors in the
effectivity and the vectors in this in
and the vectors and this this rejection
should satisfy that whenever a subset
here said easily independence that then
the corresponding vectors is an
independent set in the usual sense so if
a Maitre D' has a way to be represented
by vectors in this way it's called a
representative you know in a field F and
if the vector representation is already
given this aids represented may trade so
what we are interested in this work is
represented matrix so you can just
forget about maitre d but you can
consider that vectors are given as a
representation of a mid-major so we what
is this is the central problem of this
work so so at least I hope that you can
remember this problem at the end of this
talk even if I you even if you forget
other things so let's fix a field F and
we assume that this field is finite so
the input of this vector
arrangement problem is n vectors v1 up
to VN of dimension are so damaged on al
vector space and you are given a
positive integer the goal is to find the
linear layout like permutation linear
ordering of these factors which
satisfies the following property so what
we want is that for when you when you
have a linear ordering of these factors
you want the order of the gap for any of
the gap here between doctors should be
small so what what what do you mean that
the order of this gap is small so the
vectors vector space the subspace
spanned by the first I vectors and the
subspace spanned by the rest of the
vectors on the right side of the gap and
look at the intersection of them and we
want the dimension of these to the the
intersection of the two spaces is
bounded by K Phi I plus 1 or instead of
fight else over here hearing should be I
plus 1 yeah yes thank you yeah yeah yeah
so actually it's the same but yeah you
should be plus sorry I I tried not to
make too many people's will you have to
ok so the problem is clear
so this is a problem that we consider
through the work and such a linear
layout is said to have with Amos k and
also this is equivalently a passage of
the maitre d we represented in the over
the field F so you can so here you had a
linear layer of vertices so it's kind of
Caterpillar and instead of having
caterpillar you can allow a tree in
general and then you obtain the
definition of branches so what is branch
with so here we want to find the kind of
partition of the vectors so you can
consider it as elements of the matrix
but let's just talk about vectors
decimal cheating so you want to kind of
have a partition of the vectors and want
to represent the partition in a
hierarchical way using this tree
structure and every partition we
presented by the edge of the tree you
want this partition to have small order
in the sense that this is this has a
small water so get more formally we are
given n vectors again in this vector
space and we consider vaina field and
want to find a sub cubic tree and we
want to match the leaves with a vector
given vectors in a bijective way such
that every at every bipartition given by
edge of the tree the order is emma scale
and the order is the subspace of the
letter the one of subspace spanned by
the one part of the vectors and the
other part of vectors and they you look
at the intersection of them this is
called a branch decomposition and you
can extend this definition of branch of
the composition for any metroid with
different way of defining ordering which
is just generalizing
Oh of this definition okay so so maitre
d's is interesting one obvious way for
us is we are we are very familiar with
graphs and matrix is natural extension
of graphs in several ways so just let's
look at one example which is relevant
here so path we I kind of assumed a you
know pathways of graphs the pathways of
a graph is the same as a cycle the path
of pathways of psychometric of G prime
where G prime can be obtained in a very
simple way so suppose this is grouchy we
double every edges of G and add one apex
vertex which is adjacent with everyone
in G with double edges this is very
simple construction and then the did we
have this relation and ok again the
branch with of graph is the same as a
cycle the branch with of a cycle may
trade of G if G is not a tree so if
she's a tree then this religion doesn't
hold well just a quick reminder or you
can try if you are not familiar with
maitre d this is a very simple exercise
so cyclamate root of G is defined as
element and independent set we're at the
ground the ground set takes the edges of
G as the elements and the independence
is does the forest this is a this is a
psycho material of G and this is you can
check that this satisfies those three
properties of the matron ok so computing
the problem of computing pathways and
branch of it is interesting for matric
point of view and also it's interesting
because it's a extension of the width
parameter that we are interested as
algorithm designers
our graph theory so what is known about
the algorithm for computing pathways and
branches so when K is a fixed constant
there is a polynomial time algorithm I
mean XP algorithm which runs like n to
the o of K time and this algorithm these
are written works for general matrix so
we are so the next question is whether
we have FPT algorithm for matrices and
if if not if it's not possible then
which kind of matrix allows FPT
algorithm four pathways and Bridget okay
so before so the situation for computing
branch pathways for Metroid it seemed
kind of similar to the state of art for
pathway for crafts like 20 or 25 years
ago so let's look at how a big machinery
can help for this period three passes
problem so this is kind of a schematic
diagram for has this problem by a minor
testing I guess many of you are already
familiar with this schematic so let's
define gk as the graphs which have
passes mmos k and this is mine are
closed you know that if you know the
diffusion of minor then it's like an
easy exercise and let's define f
let's define deaf as the minimal graphs
minimal in the sense of matric I in the
sense of minor minor relation so it's a
minimal graphs among all graphs which
are my not minors of any of cheeky okay
you can you can always find such as it
then from this tool sets you can is
again an exit easy exercise that the
following relation also a graph Chi has
passed the most k if and only if G does
not contain any of the graph of F from
this defined set of calligraphic F so
whenever these two property laws you you
always this property or results and this
is the the that on the graph my no
relation any anti chain is finite this
is from this rubber simmers great graph
minor theorem and again it's easy
exercise that F is anti chain so from
here you know that F is finite and then
and also testing whether a given graph
is a minor of another graph can be
tested in a 50 time now is a quadratic
time with due to recent result so using
this property we can have easy we can
has a kind of a heavy machinery
algorithm for testing if G has pieces
Emalkay namely for every also others a
graph F in this set calligraphic f we
test if which it contains f as a minor
and the list of the tests izvinite each
test step takes fvt time so the overall
tape test takes a pity time so can we
apply this scheme or may treat testing
so I just drew I just replaced what is
here so although i replaced all the
grass by may trade here so these holes
these holes so this holes but that any
anti chain is finite this does not hold
for metroid indian origin or so and also
this the fpt time for matric minor
testing doesn't hold in for general may
trade actually a infinite anti chain of
madrid on the metro binary relation is
not very difficult to construct and for
and also it's hopeless to have FPT
algorithm for testing minor may treat
minor in general because of the
following example so a Maitre D' is
binary even only if it doesn't contain a
specific may treat called you 24 as a
minor wait so the binary matrix is
characterized by just one mind one for
Peedi minor but it is known that any
algorithm for testing a binary matrix
takes explination time given on
independence oracle you know it is
possible that testing just one made
minor containment can take explanation
time in general but the good part is
that if the maitre d's be presentable on
a final field over a final field F then
we have this well cut the order theory
like the robot
yeah so if F is rip so if a major it is
every presentable over final field F
then things are a bit different so the
picture I be a bit different ok we here
is
here is how you can use this scheme when
you know that the maitre d is FF
represented hello now MK is the set of
all matrix whose paths with amos k + f
represented this is again by now closed
and now consider f as a minimal f not
just minimal metro is but minimal every
presented matrix from these two we have
this relation and again there is a it is
already proved by gillian injuries and
Whittle some time ago that under may
treat minor relation any anti chain of f
representable matrix which has bounded
branch with is finite
and now F isn't so and if you look at
any mini mall later it [ __ ] which is
not a minor of MK then they should have
passive they should have branch with em
escape lock k plus one if it has branch
with k plus 2 then his path lead is also
k plus 2 so if you take some minor wit
then there should be a minor which as
passes k plus one so it's not minimal so
they have branches bounded k plus 1 so f
satisfy the condition of this statement
so f is finite and then we can use some
machinery by unity and make minor
testing so now we have FPT algorithm for
testing the passes a most came here are
some problems so there are too many
obstructions for passing Simoes k we
know only lower bound we don't know any
upper bound and there is no known
algorithm to generate all mine
obstructions and even if you know the
complete obstruction list and my the
minor testing algorithm that we use here
I jijantic function because it uses the
not melodic second-order logic logic
checking so it requires the huge huge
running time and also what is obtained
here at the end is only whether it has
passes the most K or not but it doesn't
actually produce the layout of the
victors so this is the state and our
result says that there is a cubic time
algorithm to decide decides a linear
layout exists or not of or a mosque a
any fix this one then you can actually
produce a linearly
and yeah this this algorithm is kind of
similar and is kind of extension of the
dynamic programming algorithm which
computes pathways for grass and it
doesn't depend on heavy machinery so you
can actually implement it and it has a
very clean neat running time which is
single exponential it's constructive and
so as a subroutine we use three
approximation algorithm for computing
branch decomposition of represented
Metroid but actually with overhead of n
you can get rid of this approximation
and make it self-contained i didn't put
in this so there it's in the middle i
think there will be some number is
something like 2 to the q times K times
theta also meaning so does the size of
the field and the size of the branch
decomposition that you are working on
and the size of the past the condition
that you aim to achieve they appear in
the exponent exponent
so
so we want to so we do dynamic
programming on branch decomposition so
in order to do this so we want to make
an encoding of all possible solutions in
a way which is compact so that is
compatible with with fpt running time
and you can actually construct the
encoding of bigger set from the encoding
of the smaller set that's what we want
to do so okay so I'll just try to convey
to feel how to create the encoding so
let's consider this very simple case
where you have so yeah you have vectors
and you have partitioned them into m 1
and m m 2 and you have some suppose you
have some ink you have some encodings of
the layouts of m1 and m2 and you want to
build something for their union so the
first knife approach is to remember the
sequence of dimension for each gap of
all possible linear layout so there will
be like n factorial linear layout where
n is the size of m1 here you have n
factorial layout of course this is too
many but this is just for sure and you
remember the dimension of this cap space
then when their intersection is empty
Eric it turns so this information the
sequence of dementia works as we would
intend so consider any intervening of
these two elements while preserving
their existing order so we have this
late layout and look at the gap space
here between v5 and you for so if this
space will kind of is kind of union of
the cap space between v5 and v2 is which
is here here and between you train you
for you to hear and actually you can
prove that it's not very difficult to
prove that the dimension of this space
is just simple some of this and this so
remembering the dimension of this cap
space is somehow important but there are
some problems of course there are too
many and they are too long how how how
do you want to make a compact another
thing is that we here we didn't consider
the case where the subspace spanned by
m1 and m2 has non empty intersection
indeed so and this is what we want to
handle so first
we have very so first in order to
compress this long sequence we use the
idea of typical sequence which is used
by bodelan doc and clogs and almost the
same thing also works for us and the
site the number of typical sequence can
be bounded by this nice room dice and to
handle the boundary space let's consider
that BB the intersection of the m1's
span of a man has been open to then
instead of remembering the dimension of
the intersection of this this pan and
this pan we remember the dimension of Le
intersection r minus the dimension of le
intersection 11 r which appears be so we
we remember the dimension sequence which
is outside of me then you can prove that
this actually gives us it works exactly
as you want so you given the dimension
sequence of two vector sets outside the
shirt boundary and if you just simply
sum them up the sequence in the way that
in the intended way then the song is
exactly the intersection space outside p
so this gives you the encoding which is
consist of L our lambda L is the space
spanned by the vectors on one side r is
the space spanned by the other side
intersects is intersection of B and
lambda is the dimension of the space of
the intersection of two else outsider p
and this gives you enough information
and you there is a way to make kit
compact and that gives you a bound on
the size of the encoding that you need
to handle this is how we encode the
problem
so actually in we are able to prove not
prove the theorem naturals for the
rearranged a linear layout sort of the
vector but linear layout of subspaces so
instead of taking individual vector you
can actually do it four subspaces and
that gives you that give that allows us
to have new algorithms first algorithm
for two problems one is a exact
algorithm exact FPT algorithm for linear
ranked with which is like linear version
of Rehnquist and another is a first fpt
approximation for linear click ways
which is like a linear version of clicks
yeah there are two obvious question one
is we have this old end to the three
factor in the running time can it be
proved it seems that there is a chance
that it can be proved to enter the w
where w is a matrix multiplication
factor and another question is whether
there is FPT algorithm four pathways or
brain trees on general metroid so the
using the heavy machinery like minor
testing doesn't seem to work but i am
not sure whether there is no hope for
that i don't know any obvious obstacle
for it if you do you know any of it this
is it thank you
comments questions so a fine-grained
question is there is there any reason to
believe that you can't push the
dependence say down all the way to
linear and have the like all of the
Gaussian elimination matrix
multiplication stuff the terms okay yeah
so actually we do most of the matrix
more motive multiplication in terms of K
actually but at the beginning we have to
set up the boundary space for all the
cuts that appear in the tree that's why
where it is all of answer comes from so
so yeah I don't think they do you think
you do okay I mean so for example we
what we do is we get basis of one
boundary space another boundary space
and once you have to know the boundary
space their time engine is the most K or
3k so from this you can get the basis of
any dimension which which is the
dimension of the parent and so for that
we use k to the three or k to the two
but at the beginning for example
Oh
maybe for computing the basis is not
into the stream ok let's go are you
later yeah anything else then let's
thank you